I have three scenarios
The cell is immersed in the solution
The cell is purple in color
This is a cell dinner
Water molecules are shown
Blue circles and solubility
Inside the water solution
Shown in yellow circles
Obviously I am overpriced in the volume of water circles
And dissolved molecules relative to cell size
But settled as well as we can imagine
What is happening now?
We assume this cell membrane
This is a biodegradable layer with optional electrophoresis
This allows the water molecules to enter and exit the cell
Thus the water molecules can get out of the cell
Inside or outside the cell inside
But suppose this is not allowed
Soluble molecules
For this reason it has optional access
Certain molecules are allowed to pass
Or appreciate it then say the test permeability
Now what you expect to happen
The first thing is possible for his moment
Concentration dissolved slightly outside the cell
From inside the cell
Hence in any moment of time
Some water molecules move in the right direction
Moving from outside the cell into the cell
Also some water molecules are in the right place
As they move from inside the cell to the outside of the cell
But what is the most likely to happen
And what will happen
After a period of time
Water molecules in the outside of the cell
We talked about it in the video characteristic Osmosis
The obstacles will be less than the solute molecules
If this molecule moves in that direction
She was making her way to the membrane
It can cross through the membrane
During this, if this molecule water
He was moving in that direction
It will be blocked by solute molecules and it may be rebound
It turns into Shadia
Thus the water molecules inside the cell have more obstacles
There is little potential for full interaction with the cell membrane
Or moving to the right direction
They are booked with dissolved particles
Although you will get
Water molecules move back and forth
In a given span of time there is a high probability
To enter the cell more than to exit
Thus the flow of water molecules into the cell
Flow of water molecules into the cell
Of H2O water molecules
In a similar case, we talk about his cell
The solution has
Concentration of dissolved molecules is less
It is important to talk about solute molecules
Molecule molecules are forbidden to go into the cell membrane
The cell membrane does not allow the dissolved molecules to enter the cell
We call this type of solution
The cell is immersed in it
We name the hypotension solution
Hypotension solution
At any time we talk about a hypotension solution
Or as we shall see, isotonic and hypertonic,
We are relatively oblivious to the concentration of dissolved molecules
Which can not pass through the cellular membrane
The word can be seen in other things
Is a term that means little of Shi and thus in this case
We have a concentration of soluble molecules in solution
From inside the cell because of this
You will get a nominal pressure
Molecules of water from outside the cell
Or from the inside of the cell
In fact the pressure will occur on the cell
The cell can expand
If the quantity is enough
It is possible to explode
Now let's go to the other scenario
In this scenario
We have an equal concentration of solubility outside
And inside, I tried to draw them that way
In this case the probability of water molecules
In a period of time
To enter from the outside to the inside
Or from the inside out, they would be themselves
So there is no flow inside or outflow
There are always water molecules
You go back and forth but it will not be
There will be no inward flow or outflow
Let's click, let me type no net
No flow
In this type of solution
Which has the same dissolved concentration in the solution
We will call it isotonic
These are isotonic solutions
Isotonic solution
This term iso refers to equal things
It has the same dissolved concentration
So there is no flow
High tension solution
The molecules of water enter the cell, the cell will expand
Looks like a balloon
Isotonic solution has no flow in it
Of course you can imagine the last scenario
Concentrate the solute higher in the outside of the cell
Therefore there is no cell inside
We can guess what will happen
First, what can we call this
Well, I have more than one thing in the solution,
Thus we will use the above term
I have more, more, over-stress.
This is an overly stressful solution.
Once again, the solute can not cross the cell membrane
But water molecules can
We have water molecules
Go outside the cell into the cell
And from inside the cell to the outside of the cell
But the potential molecules of water are present within the cell
There will be less obstacles to get out of the cell
Thus the molecules water outside the cell will enter
So we have a flow from outside the cell
We have a high probability of molecules coming out of the cell
From inside the cell to the outside
It does things that go from the outside to the inside
Because there will be more obstacles
So they will
In this solution
Water molecules evade the cell, in fact the cell may be withering
Since you lose water pressure
The cell itself can be watered in water
It is possible to see this in a real living device
If you put a red blood cell
In an over-stress solution
Water molecules will accelerate it
And will explode
Will expand
The red cell will be excessively inflated in case of excessive stress
It will naturally be in an isotonic state
Red blood cell
In fact, there is a kind of that little division
In the case in the center
But in the first case it will expand
And in the third case an over-stress solution
Water molecules will evade the red blood cell
Then you will see them wither
A few withers resemble this because
There is an outflow of water molecules